[Musique]
alors bonjour et bienvenue à cette
édition spéciale de l'entretien sur
france 24
nous sommes aujourd'hui avec vitali
klitschko le merde qui fait son frère
wladimir qui est membre des forces
territoriales vitaly merci beaucoup
alors une question toute simple quelle
est la situation à qu'ils font sur le
terrain on apprend que les forces russes
se rapprochent de la capitale où vous
êtes
bien pour l'instant la situation à kiev
n'est pas aisé nous avons beaucoup de
forces russes qui viennent du nord et de
l'est
en direction de cuillère
il se trouve à 15 20 km du centre de
kiev mais nous avons fait un cercle
autour de qui fait que nos soldats
ukrainien qui défendent kif
en fait
c'est
la cible josé forces russes les russes
tentent d'encercler
encerclé kiev pour pouvoir faire un
siège
mais nos soldats les soldats craignant
ont détruit les plans russes et nous
sommes très fiers
d'avoir des soldats extrêmement solide
qui défendent nos maisons notre ville
notre pays
la situation est sous contrôle dans la
capitale
nous avons d'électricité nous avons de
l'eau nous avons du chauffage
mais la situation n'est pas simple elle
n'est pas simple parce que
les citoyens de cliff
ont déjà passé deux semaines dans les
sous sols dans le métro nous entendons
et nous subissons ces attaques et des
bombardements
on entend des sirènes sans cesse et dès
qu'on entend la sirène il faut descendre
vers les bancaires
les gens ne paniquent pas mais
honnêtement ils sont très nerveux
et merci beaucoup pour l'aide militaire
pour les humanitaires la croix-rouge
beaucoup d'organisation puis soutiennent
le cren et nous envoient des équipements
médicaux
les envoie dans notre ville nous avons
des réserves dans notre ville mais la
ville est catastrophique pour notre pays
la logistique est interrompue l'économie
ne fonctionne pas et chaque jour des
civils meurent des enfants des femmes
des personnes âgées et bien sûr nos
soldats aussi
habile et damas
évidemment il ya une préoccupation
qui est la deuxième ville du pays car
qui répondent par des il ya des
précédents avec ce qu'ont fait les
russes à grozny alep en syrie êtes vous
préoccupé qu'il puisse y avoir un assaut
d'envergure pour essayer peut-être de
raser qui
ce n'est pas simplement une inquiétude
c'est la réalité
nous l'avons vu
et les images ne mentent pas
que la ville de kharkiv est pas
simplement d'être actif a été bombardée
marioupol aussi les quartiers de la
ville où ne vivent que des civils
des zones résidentielles ou n'y a aucune
infrastructure
d'importance militaires qui devraient
être détruits par les russes n'ont ils
ne font que détruire des vies humaines
il tue des enfants
des familles
et détruisent des maisons d habitation
qui n'ont rien à voir avec une guerre
contre
l'armée ukrainienne pour ainsi dire
comme les russes tentent de le dire
c'est tout simplement des massacres de
civils et il faut arrêter ça
ces bombardements
tout autour du pays même l'ouest du pays
est attaqué aujourd'hui
plus de mille roquettes russes
sont tombés sur le sol ukrainien ces
derniers jours
d'une énorme armée n'arme et russes
tentent d'encercler la capitale
prennent la ville de kif
il y à des combats pendant que nous
parlons des combats en cours autour de
la capitale
et les ukrainiens
se défendent avec la volonté et la fois
qu'ils défendent notre maison nos
maisons il reste sur le terrain et se
défendent oui nous avons reçu de l'aide
humanitaire
nous avons reçu
une partie de l'équipement militaire
mais c'est jamais suffisant ce n'est pas
suffisant
nous avons besoin d'agir ensemble
définitivement oui pour protéger notre
liberté notre choix nos valeurs
démocratiques du monde occidental
oui nous avons besoin de soutien
isolement économique de la russie parce
que tout dollars tout euros quelle que
soit la devise qui va dans le budget
russe qui fasse en armes pour tuer
maintenant des ukrainiens il n'y a pas
de fin en vue amine à youphil italie ne
craignez vous pas qu'il n'y ait aucune
décision prise pour mettre en place une
zone d'interdiction aérienne de la part
de l'occident même le fait de donner les
avions semble être un problème si cela
n'est pas le cas il risque d'y avoir un
bombardement aérien de kif au cours des
prochaines heures et jours n'est ce pas
là ma plus grande crainte
le message pour tout le monde nous ne
combattons pas simplement pour l'ukraine
nous ne faisons pas que défendre nos
maisons et nos familles
le danger maintenant
il est pour tout le monde en europe
cette guerre
atteint tout le monde des millions de
gens ont déjà
émigré et sont allés vers les zones de
sécurité
vers l'occident les milliers
des milliers de personnes ont déjà été
tuées
nous sommes prêts à défendre notre pays
nous combattons mais nous avons besoin
de l'aide parce que nous combattons pour
les mêmes valeurs
que vous les mêmes principes
que ceux de l'europe la raison de cette
guerre et tout le monde doit le
comprendre la raison de cette guerre
c'est parce que l'ukraine a décidé
d'être de faire partie de la famille
européenne nages les russes
veulent reconstruire l'empiré russe et
il n'accepte pas que nous soyons là ils
veulent remettre en place l'idée de
reconstruire l'union soviétique nous
faisions partie de l'union soviétique et
ne voulons pas y retourner c'est pour
cela que maintenant nous avons besoin
d'elle
nous avons besoin d'équipements
militaires et plus que l'équipement
militaire parce que nous faisons face à
l'une des armées les plus fortes du
monde l'armée russe nous avons montré
les soldats ukrainiens ont montré leur
bravoure et leur courage ils ont détruit
des avions s'est pas secret au cours des
deux derniers jours ont détruit des
avions russes qui tentait de bombarder
kif et nos soldats ont détruit ses
avions nous sommes prêts à défendre
défendre notre pays notre ville nos
familles et aussi défendre les mêmes
principes que vous avez vous en france
nous avons besoin de soutien militaire
vitaly vous participez à ces forces
territoriales est ce que vous êtes
impliqués dans les combats autour de kif
à l'heure qu'il est pour l'instant je
suis responsable que rendre service de
livrer le chauffage l'électricité l'eau
et à tout le monde et je suis avec tout
le monde je suis avec eux chaque
combattant et si besoin je prendrai des
armées je défendrai nos familles je
défendrai notre pays
combien de gens sont partis de la
capitale ils étaient 3,5 millions avant
la guerre
pour l'instant ceux qui sont partis ce
sont les femmes des enfants les hommes
sont restées actives nous pensons que il
y a environ deux millions de personnes
qui sont restés à kif kif est une des
villes les plus importantes de l'est de
l'europe nous avons construit des avants
postes et je peux promettre à tout le
monde que nous nous allons jamais nous
rendre nous allons combattre
nous nous rendrons pas nous ne rendrons
pas la ville au russe
vladimir si vous étiez en face de
vladimir poutine là que lui diriez vous
c'est pas simplement moi même
mais même le président français macron
lui a parlé à de nombreuses reprises
on ne peut pas comprendre
un esprit malade
l'adie myrte routine ne vit pas dans le
monde réel
quelqu'un dans le monde réel quelqu'un
en bonne santé mentale je ne ferai
jamais cela ne ferait jamais ce que les
russes font en ukraine tuer tuer des
innocents
affi je pense que
toutes ces négociations n'iront nulle
part qui a pas grand chose à dire
les actions sont plus fortes que les
mots l'armée russe et tuent des civils
voilà l'action voilà l'image de l'armée
russe et du président poutine
en guise de conclusion je m'adresse à
vous de allez vous rester à kiev quoi
qu'il arrive
nous restons actifs le citoyen de kiev
m'ont donné mandat de défendre la ville
de défendre les intérêts de la
population dans notre ville et c'est la
raison pour laquelle c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous restons actifs nous
défendons nos citoyens nous des toits
nous défendons notre vie d'un autre pays
moi il faut que je dise que je suis très
fier ou de nos femmes oui
particulièrement les femmes
certaines sont partis d'autres ont
laissé leurs enfants à l'ouest et sont
revenus et ont rejoint l'armée la
défense territoriale et défendent notre
pays les femmes et les hommes je suis
fier je suis fier de nos compatriotes
ukrainien et je suis fier d'être
ukrainien
moi je fais le tour de la ville je
regarde les points fortifiée et je vois
je vois les gens là bas
des civils qui jamais jamais n'ont eu
l'idée de prendre des armes et
maintenant ils ont changé et maintenant
ils sont en uniforme ils sont avec des
armes à la main des médecins des
musiciens des acteurs
des professions laiterie pacifique mais
maintenant ils n'ont plus le choix ils
doivent défendre nos enfants et nos
familles
vitalien de ladiville tally et wladimir
klitschko je vous remercie infiniment
d'avoir pris sur votre temps précieux
dans ces conditions très difficiles et
de vous adresser à france 24 de kiev la
capitale de l'ukraine un message
additionnel
restés à nos côtés l'unité unités et les
principes qui c'est la clé pour la
victoire restait aux côtés de l'ukraine
nous ne nous battons pas que pour
l'ukraine nous nous battons pour tout le
monde en europe c'est très important
l'unité c'est la clé pour la liberté
merci beaucoup pour votre soutien
soutien d'autres pays merci on nous
aimons tous pour votre soutien et kg
merci beaucoup et merci d'avoir suivi
cette édition spéciale de l'entretien
sur france 24
[Musique]